all right joining me now Congressman
Myra Flores running for reelection and
the 34th District against Congressman
Vincente Gonzalez and Congressional
candidate Cassie Garcia running in the
28th District against Congressman Henry
Cuellar and Congressional candidate
Monica De La Cruz running in the 15th
District against Michelle Vallejo
Congressman Flores let's start with you
today we learn that the Congressional
Hispanic caucus
is officially rejecting your membership
and the Congressional Hispanic caucus
because you're not a Democrat this has
to be something from one of the you know
comedy or you know sarcastic websites
out there yes or is it true it's true
I was born in Burgos tamalipas Mexico on
June 14 I became the first mexican-born
congresswoman ever elected in Congress
and that's not good enough for them and
this just shows that they're not for the
Hispanic Community they're just there
um for the their political party how are
you informed that you were not not
welcome in their Club over the phone who
was it over the phone was that
congressman's office
it was their office their office it was
office the Hispanic caucus yeah
to you no that's just not not but you
know
I don't need them the Hispanic Community
doesn't need them we are the real voice
we are the boys
and we stand for the values that we were
raised with God family and hard work
that is what we are all about
right
[Applause]
AOC recently said that not all Latinos
are leaving the Democrats just one
specific group of you are leaving the
Democrat Party check this out
there's a conversation we had about men
and male identity it's not like oh we're
we're shedding Latino voters or we're
shedding cert we're shedding men yeah
young men too men your experience it's
all it's just men leaving the
Democrat Party what I don't even know
who AOC is she's she's not part of the
Hispanic Community but I'll tell you
this Hispanic voters we are a common
sense voters we believe in the American
dream you know and we are tired of the
Biden Pelosi queer agenda we are hard
working we want a strong and secure
border and that's why we're seeing that
shift in Hispanic voters because the
Democrat Party has left the Hispanic
Community she's trying to make this out
to be a gender thing that it's the
Hispanic men I guess they're the new
white nationalists Hispanic men
according to this kind of analysis
it's like Dr Biden coming over here and
telling us that we're unique as a
breakfast taco you know we're calling us
latinx you know don't even know what
that is does anyone even recognize that
no it's trash that was just totally made
up right so that's his span right
um
Monica uh former Obama HUD secretary
Julian Castro was uh on mess NBC last
night claiming that this shift of
Hispanic voters gradually over to the
Republican party is just temporary watch
I've been pulling my hair out for the
last couple of months as I've seen story
after Story of acting as though the
Latino vote is somehow firmly a
Republican vote now my worry Joy is that
this becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
they start to think hey oh okay uh oh
folks are going Republican now there is
a bandwagon effect that I fear can
happen
I think Hispanic voters can't think for
the themselves Monica I mean they're
just bandwagon no matter what
look at the end of the day the Biden of
Pelosi economic agenda has just
destroyed the American dream for
Hispanics but it's also for all all
Texans and what we're seeing as a single
mom like myself we're seeing that
Hispanics are voting with their wallets
single moms like myself are taking two
sometimes three jobs just to put food on
the table they're concerned and that's
why I think in November we're going to
see a huge shift of Democrats continue
to leave the Democrat Party and
permanently come to the Republican Party
thank you
now
now I want all of you uh to react to
this new narrative that's being tried
the left is trying to set on this whole
topic watch
the reality is there is a lot of
anti-black racism that exists across all
aspects of our society included within
the Hispanic Community there is blatant
discrimination and racism but there's
also uh this casual racism the existence
of anti-black bias is been a recurring
uh Trend a theme a dynamic within Latino
communities you know communities so Myra
this is actually their argument that
because Latinos are beginning to again
slowly but steadily shift to the right
on some of these Common Sense issues
that it must be because of racism how
does this how how do they think they're
going to appeal to people with the
racism charge you see the Democrat Party
has walked away from the Hispanic
Community how so because my father was a
Democrat all his life and he said they
walked away from our values they are no
longer standing with God in family and
hard work they stand against everything
I raised you with everything I was
raised with and that's the reason why so
many people are are walking walking away
but in reality it's a party now they're
calling us racist racist for what for
wanting our lives back the life that we
had two years ago two years ago we had
more money in our pockets we were able
to provide for our kids now our family
are struggling to pay their rent
groceries gas these are the issues that
are impacting the American people these
are the issues that are impacting my
district and I'm 100 focused on my
constituents and I want to put the
American people first Vicente Gonzalez
wants to put the government first that's
what the Democrat Party wants and it is
time that we put all Americans first and
not be treated like second class like
we've been treated in South Texas
well Cassie when we think about what's
happened with middle class wages I mean
middle class Prosperity people have lost
about seven percent of their net worth
just in the past year under this regime
of bidens how has that impacted the
Hispanic Community given that small
businesses that were created given all
the you know two and three jobs families
are working to put food on the table as
as the congresswoman said yeah look as a
lifelong South Texan and the wife of a
border patrol agent people are hurting
in South Texas with the Biden Pelosi
agenda high prices we talk about record
inflation unsecured border people are
hurting every single day I talk to moms
they're having to make difficult
decisions whether to put gas in their
car or funeral table I met a mother who
lost her 70 year old daughter to
fentanyl two days ago because they don't
she took a sleeping a pill she thought
it would come across the border all
coming across our Southwest border and
my the incumbent Henry choir has been in
office and been in kindergarten and he's
under a criminal investigation for
corruption and right now people are fed
up with this Administration and they're
ready for change in this district and
we're meeting voters every single day so
Cassie I've been a Democrat my whole
entire life and I'm voting Republican
for you because of the values of faith
family and freedom
all right Monica
got Michelle Myers Myers from the group
known as lexit Michelle hi um so we've
found that many Hispanics don't even
know about the just
um of radical policies from
the Democrats how do we better let
Hispanics know what their policies are
because they're so extreme and many
Hispanics that we've spoken to said that
they would have never
um voted a Democrat if they had known
well what I think is that this is a
pivotal year where the Republican party
has invested dollars into South Texas
specifically and these dollars have gone
towards educating and sharing the values
of the Republican party which at the end
of the day aligned with Hispanics we
love Faith we love our family and we
believe in the American dream and hard
work and that's why I think that
Hispanics are walking away because
people like my my opponent who is a
socialist she believes in big government
meanwhile we the Republican party we
believe in God
all right ladies thank all of you for
being here tonight best of luck on the
trail we can't wait to have you back on
after you so thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else